another bus of migrants which was
carried from Texas to Los Angeles so
this is something we've seen in the news
repeatedly in this instance the the bus
left Brownsville Texas on Monday at 4 25
local time and arrived at Union Station
at 6 30. it had 45 Asylum Seekers from
various countries including Brazil Chile
China Colombia Guatemala Haiti Honduras
and Venezuela according to the Coalition
for Humane inter Humane immigrant rights
I apologize uh it mentions here in the
article that the bus included 37 adults
and eight children with the largest
group of migrants 23 people hailing from
Venezuela so it seems to me as if people
who are in states that are more wealthy
and further from the border don't have
as much of a problem with unfettered
migration and of course people in Border
towns who are actually directly affected
by it do have an issue with it now what
we often hear from left-wing activists
on this issue is there's simply a
failure of empathy on the part of people
who believe the federal government
should have any oversight over who's
crossing the border or that border
patrol should be able to do its job in
securing our border of course the irony
is they're totally incapable of being
compassionate towards people who live in
border states and actually have to
wrestle with the struggles of unfettered
migration you know look it's actually an
area for National Unity that I see here
so I ended up visiting uh now a couple
months ago now I visited the south side
of Chicago
now at eight which part I went to South
Shore okay went to other parts of South
Chicago Chicago area originally yeah
yeah so South Shore High School right
now is being converted into an
encampment for myself actually
by the way seven thousand dollars per
person per month is roughly what that
costs well that's like 90 000 a year but
yeah I mean that's exactly if you were
if you were making 90k a year and
spending all of it uh each month without
saving anything that's and not paying
your taxes like that's how much it is
untaxed right because these are illegal
migrants by definition and so people in
that town and by the way this is
far left supposedly far left territory
hard Democratic stronghold not a place
where Republican politicians go frankly
not even a place for many Democrat
politicians go
who were probably more strongly in favor
of closing the Border than even many
traditional Republican donors who I meet
with on a given basis
and that's interesting to me because
that's that's an America First principle
right it doesn't fit in the Democratic
Republican boundaries but they're asking
a legitimate question which goes back to
that earlier conversation we were having
why are we taking care of somebody else
first instead of starting right here at
home and so their question was look I
had trouble getting baby formula or
sneakers you got sneakers and baby
formula for people who are showing up
illegally into this country breaking the
law they're getting seven thousand
dollar checks what am I getting
which I think is not an unreasonable
question to ask and so anyway this issue
around border security
I think there is far more consensus in
this country across traditional
boundaries then the media would have you
believe traditional media would have you
believe certainly
I think that most Americans who I've met
support the idea that I've advanced
which is that building the wall isn't
enough I mean look you want to talk
about how fentanyl gets into this
country there's cartel financed tunnels
underneath those walls now much of what
people think they're buying is Percocet
or wheat or whatever is often even laced
now with fentanyl
but the way we solve that problem and
the migrant crisis along with it is use
our military to secure that southern
border we're now using our military
equipment and resources to secure
somebody else's border Halfway Around
the World
let's use our own military to secure our
own Southern border I think we do it for
our northern border too
that's how you address the actual crisis
and I think that there's broad consensus
around that because just walk down the
list do you believe that Nations should
have borders
some people haven't it's not a nation
it's not a nation without certainly my
belief but there are certain people who
say we shouldn't have borders and
whatever okay fine let's smoke that out
and get that on the table but that's a
tiny Fringe minority of people most
people in this country say they want
borders but then if you want borders
then okay if you believe in a border
then have a border yep and if we can't
use our own military to secure our own
border that means we don't believe in
the existence of the importance of that
border in the first place which is why I
said I would close that Loop yeah
absolutely would you end Birthright
citizenship I see Birthright citizenship
as a danger to the people who being
trapped across the border right this
promise that if you are born in America
you get to stay means that you're going
to be willing to take huge risks to get
here which we know are incredibly
dangerous to everyone involved yeah so I
would end Birthright citizenship for
illegal immigrants the children of
illegal immigrants well what does it
mean for everybody else I mean we're all
citizens whether sixth generation or
first generation in my case if you're
born in this country you have
citizenship if you're born under legal
circumstances but I think that if
somebody comes to this country illegally
and has a child while here I do think we
have to end Birthright citizenship but
does that mean you Deport like a
one-year-old I think you you do the
family you take the whole family unit so
so I'm strongly opposed to policies that
would separate kids from their parents I
think that that was discussed even in
the Trump Administration and otherwise
as a tactic for deterring people from
coming
as a pro-family leader I will not adopt
such a policy but we will send back the
family unit as such and I think that if
you came to this country illegally the
right answer is you have to be sent back
to your country of origin come back
through the same legal means getting in
the same line that everybody who's
coming into this country legally is
already pursuing I would tend to agree
with that and what a lot of people will
say is deportation is so cruel it's so
horrible when it happens all right yeah
I would agree it's not the optimal
solution or circumstance that's why we
have to have strong border security to
ensure people do not come here illegally
so that we don't have to deport people
if you're against deportation you should
be in favor of having very strong orders
the crazy thing about borders and walls
is they are not that's not where you
defend the Romans knew that that's why
the Romans invaded their neighbors
because you had to create a perimeter of
defense and I don't want to see I don't
want a war with Mexico but if they're
going to allow an invasion it's like
what other choice have they left us with
so I I think there's a couple things
that I would make as hard line policies
here
end any form of foreign aid to Mexico or
Central America until the Border crisis
is dealt with period yeah right I think
that they have not yet borne the
consequences of actually a border crisis
that actually many of those illegal
migrants crossing over aren't even
originating in Mexico they're
originating countries the majority are
not the majority of people that
overwhelm the Border are not the
overwhelming majority right and so
Mexico doesn't face any of that
accountability yet they're still a
recipient of that foreign aid and so I
think we have to use economic levels in
this case just turning off foreign aid
on less than until they've solved that
problem over there I would end Sanctuary
cities and funding for Sanctuary cities
driving the demand side of this here in
the United States I would use our
military to literally station undeployed
troops we don't need to fight a war
somewhere else on the other other side
of the world station them along our own
Southern border this is if we intended
to solve that problem and as president I
do this is how we actually end that
migrant crisis the fentanyl crisis talk
about the human trafficking crisis in
this country that's how we do it when
you say would you cap sorry would you
cap legal immigration do you have any uh
any feeling on restrictions for legal
immigration I think there should be
restrictions the restrictions are not a
specific number that we want to finish
eyes the Restriction is twofold both are
merit-based restrictions
are you going to make a contribution to
this country and then crucially there's
a second element to this too for me do
you actually know something about this
country and demonstrate a desire to be a
part of it and so this is where the the
question of Birthright citizenship goes
deeper for me
is I don't think citizenship should be
something that anybody automatically
takes for granted born here or not
I think every 18 year old should have to
pass the same Civics test that an
immigrant has to pass in order to become
a naturalized citizen in this country I
love that I think you got to know
something about the country if you want
to actually call yourself a citizen of
that Nation I think that ought to be
true if you're an immigrant I'd pull up
that Civics test not just from the
citizenship side I'd pull up a version
of that to the front end to even get
into this country it selects for people
who have taken the time to learn
something about the country who have
demonstrated themselves to want to be
part of the country and then yes to work
hard and be an industrious member of our
society contributing to our country and
so I think that should be the limit but
I think that the idea of using a number
then we're just playing tug of war
argument numbers that misses the point
this is the way we have to filter for
the kind of people who should and should
not be able to enter this country and
then just because you're born here
doesn't mean that the act of just being
born you're born and happened to have
arbitrarily been in the United States of
America you know there's something
beautiful about Birthright citizenship
in the American experiment which is to
say that your citizenship in this
country is not based on your ethnicity
or you're allegiance to a monarch or
even your religion
that it's anybody who's born here can be
a citizen I would take that to the next
level to say it's not just about being
born here but anybody who truly makes
contributions to this country and
pledges allegiance to this country and
knows something about the country
they're the ones who actually are the
true Capital citizens and that's I mean
many people find that view radical maybe
it is it's not I don't think that's
radical at all I've heard your plan out
of the radicals bad yeah well this is
something I've heard you say in the past
that you would you would have people who
were over the age of 18 take a Civics
test before they're able to vote and
then once they get to 25 they can vote
in general but you would restrict voting
between those uh or between that that
age Gap I actually happen to think that
that's a good idea I don't know that I'm
saying I would specifically endorse that
exact policy or how I would flesh out
but when I hear it it sounds right to me
because historically in this country the
voting age was 21 years old and this was
at a time when you were expected to be
on your own taking care of yourself at
the age of 16. so by the time you got to
voting age you you knew a thing or two
about the world You'd Survive down your
own you'd paid your rent so to speak you
knew what life was like for other people
I remember when I was in high school I
graduated 10 years ago I hadn't turned
18 by the time the election happened but
I remember a friend of mine went out and
he voted for Obama why because he didn't
know anything about Obama he didn't
really listen to any of his speeches but
well I think he's the guy who wants to
legalize weed so I'm voting for him I'm
sorry 18 year olds are not in a position
where they know enough about the world
where they're qualified to vote and if
they are in that position they are a
minority and we should have a kind of
test to vet for those people I think
that's perfectly legit it's the exact
same test I'm not making up some new
tests from scratch it's the exact same
test we've decided
that an immigrant has to pass in order
to become a voting citizen of this
country I'll give you examples of what
they ask in the test I mean how many
branches of government are there what
are they what branch of government does
the U.S president lead
is it so objectionable to say if you're
voting for U.S president that you know
what branch of government the U.S
president actually leaves I think it is
not no and so so
the implementation of this proposal it's
been a little while since I talked about
it and it wasn't
I think people will believe me when I
say this I was not doing this to score
political points this did not pull
particularly well as an idea my job is
to persuade people yeah that this is
what we need to revive in our country so
right now I'll remind you something that
a lot of people forget
we have a Selective Service requirement
in the U.S that's right men between the
age of 18 and 25 have to on pain of
criminal penalty that means potentially
going to jail register for Selective
Service that's the draft we don't have
an active draft but if you don't
register between the age of 18 to 25
you're doing so at behest of criminal
penalties
I would decriminalize that
I don't think that should be the way we
do things here
but in replacement of that I said you're
free you're not going to jail whether or
not you register for Selective Service
but if you want the ultimate Civic
privilege in this country of voting
before the age of 25 then pass the darn
Civics test and if tests aren't for you
then serve the country for six months
either in the military or in a first
responder role thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time